ya know welcome to this broadcast yeah
as announced i was a little bit little
bit late three minutes but this is still
within reason it's not unreasonably late
yeah i hope you are all alright watching
life here on the on twitch probably the
last twitch stream for a while because
i'm hoping to switch to youtube anyway i
hope you are alright hello to meat
grinder solando che be some regulars on
them yeah thanks for telling me I'm live
i'm now always checking myself with the
with the view of the of the actual
stream in the background okie dokie
let's start with some five-minute games
and i'm playing geheime pull each side
which is the secret police that's a
German German name of course um what to
do against the guy who put its I let's
co e six maybe some Queens gambit stay
solid it doesn't have a name I think I
mean not openly published nope yes I've
seen mama dr oz blunder that was pretty
awful yeah it was a guide surprising to
see such a move I think he I think he
simply made the the second move ahead of
the the first one he was he wanted to
play something to be 6m rugby six and
then then continue with this with his
play with them what was that c5 there it
was just the wrong water okay I'm
playing this interesting position that
was discussed recently in another
video not of mine but video on YouTube
and I learned that this is a viable line
for black just wonder if before now as
possible I think it is it looks a little
bit awkward I didn't do that okay okay I
think I'm castling here still might go
here for takes 90 x is what worries me
nope okay well yes that night on on f5
but I don't think that this is a big
deal I can play Knight b6 cat6 and
challenge that doesn't seem too bad yeah
this is the first game absolutely will I
play the orangutang mm-hmm I don't think
so as I said today in a video that I was
releasing on one rare openings I don't
think the rang a tang is a terribly bad
opening it just isn't very great i mean
i don't see much point in playing it but
it shouldn't lead to a huge edge for
black okay but should be form okay so
let's regroup here for for this I don't
know maybe Bishop before ultimately
didn't net much 92 wasn't a bad reply
gen 96 here or maybe I just take this
huh that's not a bad idea actually just
grab this thing and play ruki aid yeah
any opening or all openings named after
an animal are bad this is probably true
and the dragon is not strictly an animal
probably some kind of animal okay anyway
I like my position here unless I'm
blundering the before bishop or
something Queen a4 was interesting maybe
not at this particular moment but in
general the head shock yeah the Hedgehog
is not terrible yeah I have to have to
agree and the hippopotamus is not is
also not terrible it is not great but it
is not not not rubbish or anything
okay so i think my position is okay yeah
right my d6 night down is doing a good
job what is he going forward this nida
kept going here Quincy five maybe could
be on how I cook back I have some
pressure only three year it's not bad at
all I love my night on d6 a covering
f-fire firm everything under control
very nice um okay what now he's looking
at age four but he's not going to win
this porn
hmm
Queen f2 where is that really happening
maybe hmm i'm not quite sure about this
I shouldn't be in so in such a bad shape
but I couldn't really find something
completely convincing here
that looks a bit uncomfortable maybe
this and Bishop g5 took me a while to
see that but it's an idea and something
that I should have spotted quicker
yeah I've got this counter play only
three now is he taking f7 and exchanging
that 43 I'm not sure I have to do this
anyway not a big choice yeah that that
doesn't look bad right either check Oh
check for Quincy seven whoa that could
be an issue I saw Queen edge to really
late hmm ok wasn't played
Queen 37's may be coming if I play rook
e1 text x takes King at to Quincy one
you see checkmating me there doesn't
have that check check there check check
I don't see it okay I have no time
though that's a problem maybe you just
moves the king that's possible okay I
still have this for Quincy for made rook
takes no wait wait wait wait here can
actually check 1c4 as well be 3 however
okay I thought that this was okay i
might be wrong but I thought this was
okay I didn't see him made for him here
and I'm threatening Quincy for myself
I ok I can flick winner forward that's
not threatening me might be enough to
win on time but I don't see anything
great here check on fa door so it
doesn't lead anywhere
yeah okay tries for for the time maybe
that was the only way anyway that's
possible
is there some way to be five is a pretty
awkward mating idea and I'm head on the
clock that looks good route d3 is a huge
huge idea okay there's no there's no
stalemate him I think you resigned him
yeah so good fight so so what do we have
any any yeah also welcome to many others
in the chat math dog five-card draw
bioshock wats igniting ideas and so on
okay so let's get going with a new game
i'm happy to get a winning for the start
of the session and
yes I'm discussion in the chat about
about food always interesting to follow
I'm not quite sure how it came to that
what kind of flag is that I'm pretty
curious there what kind of like us that
neway what kind of what is that and I we
are never heard of that okay so funny
funny account vice city on two of the
prodigies Sam civilian and ye mmm ok
yeah two nights let's see what happens
95 yeah I'm not really knowledgeable
here so this is going to be risky but
what can you do
or do you start with 95 maybe you do
maybe age six is rubbish that possible
net is probably some some Island hmm
what is this i have no idea i just have
to make it up here it's f5 and move
voice that rubbish probably it is
rubbish mg3 is good g3 takes takes f4
well it looks funny at least yeah so it
stops there interesting um can i play
probably i can write but it still looks
kind of interesting oh it doesn't look
like i have completely screw this up
should be some kind of compensation
okay I have to take and now he tries to
play some D for him hmm hmm that's
something i can easily spend time on hmm
maybe go here I don't know I have to
have to be a bit quick IAM making it a
little bit more difficult for him to
sort his position them okay so let's
ditch that pawn and go for Queen age for
it was my idea probably probably deform
know okay um ok let's threaten checkmate
or close to that
looks difficult Queen d2 I'll take be to
that looks pretty awkward looks awkward
for white queen e 3 i'll probably just
move the Queen back to the six or
something I don't see a good move to be
honest we had some stuff like that but
that's not something that looks very
very tempting okay check on the eight is
the most obvious move
ok let's go for that
and how to play it sister this is a
super brutal position ff4 it's 94 that
cannot be right
c3i will take so maybe I should try to
double on the e-file it's it's very hard
in this position to be precise now I'm
gonna have to take before this rookie
aid I guess I know where position is
also not perfectly harmonious so it
might be not working castles maybe okay
take first think later yeah before but
this is not clear here a couple of
interesting options and just here maybe
492 if he takes it is definitely not bad
for me question is how good is it so
Queen to the ones maybe around the
corner I would love to get the rook into
the game somehow and I will probably
have to take
and now maybe f4 is good or is there
some way Queen to h4 would be great look
b2 is actually threatening know it isn't
but it's kind of funky still 21 23 as an
Easton is a nice little trick that could
be interesting yeah okay I think it
works at least maybe it doesn't but so
what now I think here right covering at
five and Queen takes h2s meet ya cannot
cover h2 now oh we can actually I could
have played Queen c7 yeah so that was a
win funny funny game at least I have no
idea what happened but you sometimes you
just have to fire and hope for the best
okay new game the games has so crazy I
have to I have to ignore the chat it
sometimes okay there was at least fun
let's see what we can do against
Westphalia here yeah 2500 on stream
would be really nice but we know it's
tough I've gotten two times to that
rating but I mean with that account I've
ever been there more than once with
earlier accounts so what do we have
Kings Indian
yeah there was an interesting piece of
discussion there about what kind of food
to go for like that what we in Germany
call Bo which is kind of a bio which is
kind of yeah well everything is kind of
bio and what what you eat in a way what
it is in English is like organic food on
or just like usual kind of food is this
is an interesting discussion I have
thought about this quite a bit what to
what to buy what kind of supermarkets to
to buy food and and so on and I think it
is interesting to try out some things
yeah for example when I when I tried out
I'm not a vegetarian as still eat meat
not not a lot but I do and when I was
shooting for I was trying for to get
this organic meat yeah something that is
much more expensive than the than the
meat that you get in a discount a
supermarket and the difference is
astounding it's really astounding it
tastes a lot better and you know you
kind of you you you really see the
different type of quality and you can
only i mean the the price difference is
absolutely this is great between between
the two and yo you can pretty logically
deduct how bad the circumstances must be
for the animals for ya that have that
that was slaughtered for that for that
cheap achieve meet you know and me
personally have stopped to do eat any
any meat that is not if possible from
some kind of local farm or stuff like
that if possible i think this is some
this is something that you should turn
you should try out just
see how much better the the good meters
and yeah I think think about this a
little bit i think it's it's an
interesting point okay so i've got a
slight advantage I think here in this in
this Kings Indian um it's nothing
dramatic but I think I'm kind of okay
here d 5 hmm i don't like that so much i
can still do that okay I will I think
even if it takes you three F Bishop age
6 yeah local farmers certainly can also
be cruel to the animals but um yeah i
mean just try to look at this with some
kind of yeah think about what you want
to buy them and really check how it
tastes us the difference is really
really great anyway i think that i
probably made a mistake now that doesn't
seem right okay maybe i can still play
this year 95 95 as possible but it isn't
as good as I thought I am I really don't
want to make use this discussion out of
that that food thing I think it's very
important that this is everybody's own
business you you shouldn't be in any way
condescending to people who have other
opinions it's just that I think it's a
good idea to try that out so here I
don't really know him I rookies hanging
look the one he just goes back look
Yvonne bishops III unfortunately is kind
of annoying
yeah maybe with the beep on mmm I didn't
think about this one now 494 hmm not
good
wow there's a bad game be sure I cannot
even take on e6 trying to make an
exchange psycho out of it not even that
is possible and look bit too there's 94
that's that's that's a really really big
issue but nothing else
so it doesn't want to take the exchange
I'm not quite sure why it was certainly
possible I mean I mean he's clearly
better here as well but he just could
have taken the exchange without any big
issue okay I think I'm pushing this
what surprised I mean maybe I'm still
kind of alive here of course is better
this is this is no question but still
maybe queen age 6 can be an issue it's
it's kind of its kind of them yeah it's
not exactly rocket science in my counter
play
let's try this I have a hard time with
the question today to be on to be honest
though the games are so tricky
look f3 maybe wow wow really that is
that looks dangerous okay we should be
for this 96 ok let's try if I can enter
their Queen f7 asst I think he's kind of
screwing this up Queen two is six mmm I
know and it doesn't really have a big
threat coming this is the problem really
night he ran a check doesn't really lead
to much hmm I wonder still Queenie six
it doesn't threaten much rook g3 is not
a threat unfortunately as special f2 is
hanging hmm maybe this is objectively
best
I don't see a continuation and wanted to
take on c5 but it also wasn't good I
think wow okay
get to the g6 porn okay I'm taking wow
that looks dangerous it looks dangerous
I think he's getting miss getting his
eye and cheek made it I don't believe
this stuff he's got 20 seconds on the
clock I didn't see the maid ah I can
just take this rook I can just take the
rook what kind of stuff is that oh my
god this is why I'm not getting to 2500
I'm just too impractical yeah I wanted
to still play good good chess and not
just win on time oh my goodness in okay
let's shoot for the next game poor I was
kind of wondering why i said so
dangerous all of a sudden yes because I
can take everything I didn't do that and
I was very silly to loosening him its
water no absolutely no what come why
don't I get a game there I have
requested one ah what a nonsensical game
and this is costing like 23 points am
unbelievable okay
um yeah I think we pretty much finished
that subject of of our food I just
wanted to say one thing that I wanted to
clarify i think what i said earlier is
that I feel like what I don't like is
people wanting to kind of yeah to their
opinion to that a particular opinion is
used to kind of yeah to arrest people
like you have to do with something
something in particular you have to eat
this kind of way and so on this is not a
good way to do things I mean I think the
information is out there what is yeah
what what what you can do what you
should do maybe and it doesn't help to
to um yeah to influence people on over
again what they should do and what they
shouldn't do it's it's everybody's own
own choice let's say okay well I wonder
who that is and you at one point pretty
long ride GM Accardi rotstein high
supreme good GM know what cam yeah I
have no vodka but don't even have any
vodka at home him
so can develop that and you five is
hanging em what to do what to do with
that I had Bishop to g5 in mind but
night h4 could be a little bit okay I
can go back
now these are the centralized but those
pawns are somewhat weak now a week is a
bit much but there's somewhat vulnerable
knowledge for I will go back so it's
probably okay tries to go for you for
whom that makes an awful lot of sense
actually I don't like to but i think i
have two nite h4 though again now that
i'm not playing this well that looks bad
or this one ng6 looks awfully weakening
but maybe it's okay maybe it's okay
now I don't know that hearthstone this
is something coming from said from World
of Warcraft I know that is very popular
but I have no idea how it works I at all
I wonder what he's trying to do here to
be honest unless there's some kind of
tactic I think I'm fine my pieces are
well centralized bishop on d5 and yeah
this is an interesting question i can i
can take that but he will take with the
e pawn which is which is really annoying
hmm i don't like that ok I have to do
this I think
you
my opponent is in his late 40s I'd say
something like that so I mean old old is
always relative I would compare to many
others but still not like old old old
okay I'm basically forcing him to take
if he's not taking and I know 94 it's
pretty awkward so he will take on d5 I
guess wow I thought that this is kind of
awkward okay maybe it's not a big deal
but still um
so how to do that him Queen over to age
six would be good good to get that is he
said that Bishop age three coming up
yeah maybe nice attacking you form hmm
ok let's do that it wasn't wasn't as bad
as I thought
no one was bad at all okay let's see if
I can get something going them need Kyle
to play whatever I cannot move my knight
this is a bit of a problem and he has
potential exchange Sykes this is why I'm
covering the five him
okay some rook h7 or weak c7 this is
more likely actually I'd like to do
stuff on the C file okay
still want possibilities on f2 here
Brooks you want my pawn on d5 is quite
ok I can maybe you can take now I shoot
that's bad I just saw that the whole
time coming and why didn't I play rook
c5 I don't think he's got anything about
divan ah that's stupid it's really bad
handing him this life handing him this
like like that ah awful
ah very unnecessary as well this is the
thing on the other hand how does he
cover f2 if we are perfectly honest
there Luke age five King g6 and this is
actually pretty bad for him maybe I'm
okay
huh I think I'm okay yeah yet to do that
I guess and it's not not a happy move
funny I was really thinking I'd screw it
up but that wasn't the case weird weird
no I have not watched porn sacrifice yet
and I don't think i will actually sound
it too awkward to me and well it's not
that I'm going to learn anything about
that match or about Fisher that I didn't
know before and probably a lots of it
has lots of weird information or we had
start where they changed what actually
happened and so on so i don't i don't
really feel like I'm missing out on much
okay I'm requesting a new game but the
term takes a moment somehow I'm not
scope I cannot pronounce it um yeah
let's go some lighter three there's a
question if chess is solved completely
which we were probably not witness but
anyway is that the draw is it a win for
any site or would wide win it will be
drawn one hundred percent of the time I
mean I'm 100-percent show that it's a
draw
the thing that I've always yeah what I'm
always mentioning in this in this regard
is that famous draw with an extra Bishop
and pawn that cannot be won because of
the wrong color of the of the of the
promotion square you cannot win with the
bishop up and a porn up in some
positions which seems kind of ridiculous
but if it is like that then it's very
likely that black gum that black can
escape to this kind of thing
yeah i think that parts of parts of
chess some some parts of opening theory
might be possible to completely am yeah
how do you call it that you can
completely clarify what is going on
there it is a drawer whatever is a
certainty pasa or very likely possible
with some sharp lines so I'm making I'm
playing some some weird piece maneuvers
to pressure rises t6 pawn probably it
won't lead to much but well queen nia
three at least have a threat I'm going
down I know it's a very cheap threat but
still I was actually thinking that black
probably plays Queen c7 and then I
wanted to play two double on the D farm
maybe maybe this is them this is a
position that he go that I can play d 5
by the way it could be a move I'm just
thinking about it hmm d5 bishop is 7d
takes e4 who maybe i blundered TM i
think i blundered d5 is good for black
eye is taking long man shoot I'm playing
badly playing badly him
just just to ease 3m why not just to III
it's the same thing just without that
little kindergarten trick now I'm just
totally lost now what a nonsensical way
of playing amazing
oh my god
somehow I remember I think I played the
same as some some similar rubbish last
time against him there when well maybe
now can even go to be too not right now
but everything in before maybe to trap
his Bishop but simply doesn't work
no hmm there's some way I mean 97 that's
it that's not going to happen I guess
97 is now making it very easy for him no
not doing that
yeah I can resign actually but I just
hate to result especially when I know
that I mean I have a huge plus Kauai and
subscribe and normally win games pretty
easily actually against him so I really
hate your result it's given me a phone
am Brooke t5m Queenie a check but it
probably doesn't doesn't matter much
position is still pretty much lost
there are two points it's not enough and
you can take on edge for probably if he
is sharp 1997 I'm probably not a good
idea
I am do you see this has to find some
moves I mean it's not difficult or
anything but well maybe night f4 is a
little idea now it's taking a long time
hmm he wants to check HERE Kingi 2nite
h4 I think this is the idea
can be six check into 2nite edge for
text x Quincy for checkin that it's very
good actually hmm he played that well
rook c8 was a good move for Roxy one
the trades h5 is hanging that's not easy
at all then okay
hmm nice is messed it up a little bit at
least got three points now okay
at one time Wow I don't know it was just
a bad game swindled him out of his
well-deserved point yeah no plot playing
so well but you have to be be tricky at
least pose problems yeah overlooking d45
was pretty awful yeah I go fix mixer go
fix Mick says never give up never
surrender yeah Winston Churchill was
right it applies to chest as well I came
so this is one of them one of the modern
ways to play against b3 here with black
it usually leads to a decent position f4
Wow ok Bishop ok that's still not bad
just trade stuff here that Bishop is
strong and default looks somewhat anti
positional so I don't believe that this
is happening ok just give five I guess
Quincy one talk about a move that I
absolutely did not expect isn'ta for
good it looks like very normal okay
let's do that yeah against 1b3 you can
play many things um I think if I've is
the most principled choice but it's
definitely not not the only one okay I'm
trying for it before simple simple means
now but isn't that dangerous here he's
got an awfully weak background so Queen
edge for here yeah let's go clean edge
for okay
wow it looks that looks amazingly wrong
prob white but how to how to do that
okay I think okay i'm shooting for that
now i have to strike now or he's going
to somehow untangle this stuff click on
h2 i didn't calculate that but it should
be it should be right I don't know my
gut feeling is that this is the right
move King takes bishop age three
something like that I cannot go to eat
too unfortunately which is really a
shame okay let's grab and now how to do
a rookie to wherever I don't have that
Bishop b5 you will take maybe still
maybe this move takes rook takes
attacking the bishop and threatening
rook g5 it could be something it looks I
don't know yeah I'm going for it bishops
is six I think rook g5 works Bishop c655
rook g5 what is she doing against that
rook f3 maybe the check there he's got
Bishop g2 maybe I should take first
actually rookie 2 is still in the mix a
I can take first i think i have rookie
to and rook g5 this I Scott Brooke f3 ah
oh my goodness is he surviving this crap
that that would be hugely unfair
yeah I think he survives this nonsense
oh my god that is not fair and I kind of
sacrifice that in the wrong way there
was certainly just lost for white
somehow but I couldn't I didn't find the
right way to kill him okay so I still
try I mean it looks like he might have
to find the odd precise move maybe I'm
certainly lost now but you never know I
mean he really he played into that
terrible position in the first place so
you never know he might make some some
other mistakes oops I'm sorry so go here
the Queen fo unfortunately is very very
winning yeah I always hate that getting
letting people get away with terrible
play something like that I mean around
here that there must be some kind of win
for black that looks awful I mean maybe
just about holes but this is kind of
Quincy 191 is out of some kind of well
anyway hard to believe ok so I'm going
to play one more game I was a little bit
on later anyway keeley on with black
this is a can of course possible almost
it worst possible game that you can get
he's pretty good and I'm already a
little bit tired and after that session
ok but ok I like this position that's
usually quite nice for Black Sea for my
ok goatee phone
is eve or i mean ii for is a move I just
wonder if it is good here maybe it's a
bit too ambitious okay I'm taking
at least it's not all a gas I would have
actually preferred all the gas to him
because when I guess you always know
what tab what's going to happen he plays
the most boring crap possible and wants
to win on time Killian is actually a
good player I mean he wants to outplay
you and play good good moves which all
against does not want to do he just
wants to play into a dead end game and
tween on time and now this is what it is
anyway and so let's see what happens
here it's a fairly interesting position
yeah my nights are both positioned so
that they can possibly attack d3 this is
why I developed them in this way
hmm didn't expect this move ever ever
played an exciting fighting game against
all I gasm depends yeah I've won it came
I think once in the black majima gambit
of all openings that was kind of kind of
funny but it's and and I and I also won
some some black game once I remember I
won like two or three games I don't know
my my biggest problem actually is that
I'm I'm really better than him in
dynamic positions but I don't get them I
don't know how to get them especially
with black yeah he's always playing
Knight c3 and playing super solid you
cannot play the Kings Indian he will
exchange and he will always straight up
everything and I I have no idea how to
get an interesting position against him
with black am with white I mean I don't
know but the thing is i could probably
get more interesting positions but i
would really need to sit down and
prepare for those games and i'm not
going to prepare for blitz games i'm not
doing that okay um this is looking quite
nice actually
I just keep this on the board still
attacking see form
looks pretty good for me
now I really don't have I really don't
have time to prepare for blitz games and
absolutely not yeah my position he has
excellent he has a hard time to defend
c4 in the first place don't see a good
move home
Quincy Quincy one have 93 I also be five
by the way it's also strong Quincy
wouldn't be five so he actually he
ultimately decided to take ok so I'm
going to take him and Luke them okay
maybe look the end support the porn
okay so if i go nite 284 how are you
keeping things together the night on d
to them I think I win material now
so I think he has to trade queens now
basically and the sea pawn we win the
game it was a good game i think it
looked looked decent not some swindle
but but a good game i won that ok ok so
um I hope you liked the stream it wasn't
up and down struggle some weird stuff
happening I could have taken rooks and
so on yeah so but it was a good game and
all ends all is well that ends well or
something like that is that what Magnus
said without her after his win in Qatar
anyway I help you in joint the stream
I'm happy to have played some decent
games and make sure to watch the
coverage what sort of Tata Steel on my
channel or by the ICC they also have
game of the day thanks for watching bye
bye